this last installment of my learn from
the legend will be focusing on what is
the guy that's known as the hero of
Hastings the strongest American chess
player after Paul Morphy
the man the legend the never world
championship contender Harry Nelson
Pillsbury so Pillsbury was kind of a
flame in chess he grew into a wildfire
very quickly but he extinguished also
almost as quickly as he showed up in the
chess world
Pillsbury was a you know some lanky dude
from Massachusetts kind of tall a chain
cigar smoker apparently a really nice
guy he learned how to play chess when he
was 16 years old
relatively late for today's standards
and he joined the Brooklyn chess club by
the age of 19 he was considered to be
the strongest player in America and with
a slight amount of fame he decided to
become a professional at the age of 20
and at the age of 22 he was invited to
one of the most prestigious tournaments
ever held so we're gonna be taking a
quick look at Hastings 1895 it's kind of
long time ago but Hastings 1895 was a
monumental tournament for its time first
of all the size the tournament size was
huge of 22 players it was an all play
all tournament since most tournaments
back then were all play all and it had
some of the strongest figures in the
chess world back then in 1895 reigning
world champion was back Laskaris
world champion steinitz had just lost
this world championship but it wasn't
just them you know of course they were
the strongest and the top dogs in the
tournament but there were a lot of
strong players here we got
mikail she Godin contender more than
once to the world championship title
secret perish from Germany one of the
strongest players to never make world
champion and even going down the list we
have a lot of famous names Karl
Schlachter as we were talking about
earlier a world champion contender we
had already made a lecture on the Black
Death
Blackburn then Janowski was one of the
most famous players of his time a very
strong attacking player we have James
Mason a famous author
ammos Bern excellent player one of the
top players of the time ICI door goons
Berg was playing also a world champion
contender
Henry Byrd who came up with the Byrd
opening was also very famous for his
attacking style out of almond we also
have an opening named after him the
Alban counter gambit even at the very
lowest of positions we have Jack's Mises
one of the strongest players of his time
so this was a this was a tournament just
stacked you know everybody here was
strong this were this was by far the
strongest tournament that had been held
to that point and actually was a little
bit of a mystery that Pillsbury got
invited he was not well known yet and he
hadn't really want anything but you know
nobody really expected Pillsbury to do
anything in this tournament so you can
see he he really I mean he hadn't won a
single tournament he never really
participated outside of just in America
so he was relatively unknown in the
European scene Hastings was a huge
tournament with a fabulous prize so if I
think it was a hundred and fifty pounds
for first place which even though by
today's standards you know you can't
really buy more than dinner at expensive
London restaurant back then it was quite
a wage I mean it was it was a very
decent price
Pillsbury started out with loss against
chigorin in the very first round of this
tournament something that you know was
perhaps not entirely surprising since
chigorin was already known as one of the
strongest players of his time
however he pretty much came back with a
vengeance after that this is where he
scored nine and a half out of this next
ten he did get stopped by Alaska at some
point and yes this are not by rounds
they're just by standing since I say
this isn't the swiss pairing like you
know this is a round robin so it's
simply done by final position but he did
start losing to chigorin and then he
beat Arash on the second round and went
on to score nine out of ten in his next
games and by round 17 it had become a
very close race
it was Laskin xi goring and pillsbury
tied with 13 and a half out of 17 and in
the final stretch it was Pillsbury that
I was able to score the most amount of
points and he won't Hastings which was
incredible the guy received incredible
amount of attention in the American
media upon returning from Hastings he
had been in a tournament that was
populated by Lasker by Steinitz by Chi
goring people started calling him world
champion incorrectly assuming that this
was one but Pillsbury was a very
interesting fella he died very young he
died at the age of 33 he contracted
syphilis and well his illness caused him
to not be able to play chess to his full
potential really one of the losses for
chess kind of the same way that morphe
you know it was explained extinguished
very very quickly he was not able to
keep up his playing strength simply
because of health reasons we're gonna
take a look at a couple of Pillsbury's
more iconic games Spilsbury never again
was able to reach a performance of this
level even though he kept with very
strong performances he tied for second
in Vienna 1890 he had a very strong
showing in st. Petersburg only a few
months after this he never actually won
Hastings you know he didn't show as much
expertise as he did in this tournament
he was also known as a performer he had
a lot of tricks he was known for being a
very strong blindfold player back in the
late 1890s he was able to host a twenty
two board blindfold simultaneous
exhibition which is rather remarkable
especially for that age while he was
doing that he was known to play cards
and memorize words so people would come
up to him with like a random list of
words he'll look at it and remember it
and then just recite them backwards and
you know that was him he hadn't he had a
splendid memory last year wrote about
him that he was a very hard worker over
the board he was known as a gentleman
and in his style in chess was actually
kind of strange so we're gonna take a
look at some of his games as soon as I
find them yeah and we're gonna start
probably with one of his most famous
victories this is not from Hastings this
is from determining st. Petersburg and
I'll get to this tournament a little bit
later but I just wanted to show you guys
probably his most famous game to start
off with here he is black against M&Y
Alaska reigning world champion the game
starts efore be 5 9 f3 Knight f6 pretty
normal Petrov 95 d6 night of 394 d4 d5
nowadays this is known as well-known
theory Bishop d3 Bishop e7 castles
knight c6 nowadays after rook e1 as c4
is more common but okay whatever rook e1
Bishop c4 c3 f5 Queen b3 castles
we had a very interesting situation
after Bishop f4 last year kind of
unusually decided that he wanted to
weaken his queen his King said in order
to drive out the night from efore he
thought that it would be worth it more
or less to weaken that side of the board
in order to regain control over the
center have the pair of Bishops and
continue his pressure on the Queen side
so after Bishop takes pawn takes Knight
g5 Lasker defended from the dual threat
on f3 and h3 with King g2 Queen d7 and
Lasker play the move Queen c2 and here
pillsbury
with this advantage of structure
demolished Alaska 96 the bishop had to
retreat to c1 if Bishop e5 then after
Knight takes D takes Knight f4 Chuck
there's not just this monstrous there's
just nothing stopping that night so
Bishop c1 was better then Bishop d6 was
play again vying for control over the f4
square 92 now instead of Knight f4 check
which is also a good move those are
afraid they even more clever rookie a
after 9 F 190 takes d4 just complete
demolition cannot take on d4 because
this guy's hanging Queen d1 rook takes
rook takes and even though blacks
winning here he was actually super
precise 9 takes f3 King takes f3 f4 a
quiet move before the storm really hits
the Queen threatens to invade on h3 as
well as the pawn simply wants to
participate in the attack very very
precise Queen D 195 Chuck
if for example something along the lines
of King G 2 then F 3 is pretty fatal
Laska Richard III - but after Queen g 4
check community - Queen takes D 1 Lasker
is simply down to pons and it's not like
his position is any good
after King e 2 and some further moves
Lasker had to resign absolutely crushed
like a kid basically Pillsbury had that
knack he actually made a lot of
grandmasters well not grandmasters
officially yet but some of the masters
of his time simply looked like they
didn't know how to play chess he had a
very very strong style he was good at
calculating he had a lot of intuition
for the positional details of positions
he may not have been the greatest
theoretician of his time but he was able
to figure out a lot of things over the
board he worked really hard over the
board one of his veteran games was this
absolutely crucial game I guess easy
dude goons burg so it's the last round
of hasting and people are Pillsbury's
currently in first place a miracle
happened in the earlier rounds Lasker
was defeated by Irish in round 19 and
chigorin was annihilated by Janowski in
16 moves I also quite kind of famous
game
yeah Chi Guardian was destroyed by
yanovskiy and since last year loss to
tarush pillsbury was half a point ahead
on the field so he absolutely had to
beat goons Bell to keep his advantage
but a draw was enough to clinch first
place at least tie for first so this is
his game against his hitter Ginsburg in
Hastings last round the position is the
game itself was not terribly exciting
but the final combinations are in my
opinion quite nice Philidor gained a
little bit of an advantage from the
opening without it being too special he
has a slight a space advantage she's
gonna have easier access on the C file
and his bishop is slightly better than
his opponents despite the fact that it's
currently trapped behind his pawn
structure because it has access to be
four and a five and to c5 after rook c8
king he to e6 or HF Siwan I mean
probably in a professional game nowadays
just what I'm in a drop but okay this is
1895 Bishop f8 takes takes rook c1 takes
takes now probably you know Kramnik and
Aronian will shake hands and go to their
room and call it a day but there's still
a lot of play left and it's kind of
funny but one of the things that I like
learning from the older generation of
players is that games were never truly
over and it this is true at a certain
level like when you're 2,100 and you
have this endgame it's not a draw it's
just equal like you can you can outplay
somebody in this position you have a
slightly better King and you know
there's tricks people this is not that a
lot of people simply give up in this
kind of end games but it's not sure if
there's still a lot of play here a
bishop before King g7 and then slide
subtleties like line annoyances that
make position like make people make
mistakes
for example after Bishop c5 suddenly
black has to think do I really want to
take this bishop do I really want to
give him a passport if I take this
Bishop don't I take it with my bishop do
I want to take it with the night what am
I going to do with the pin if I don't
trade off the bishop my pawn on a 7 is
hanging you know it's not like it's the
end of the world there's probably a
solution but if you keep
putting pressure on your opponent's if
you keep making them solve problems
eventually they crack so a six was
played before knowing that this night
will not really reach c4 anytime soon f6
g4 and now the advantage of space Bishop
c5 an excellent decision take with
opponent be take c5 and 98 and here we
start I think one of the prettier
Pillsbury combinations I've ever seen it
starts with a move f5 the move itself is
easy to find if black takes twice Knight
f4 regains the pawn with clearly
decisive effect as it will give me to
pass pawns on c5 and d4 that simply roll
forward that part is clear the question
is what happens if g5 clearly pawn takes
pawn takes leads nothing as the king can
now protect the d5 square also it
possible is to first play knight c6
avoiding the knight the square b4 and
taking e6 on the next move however
Pillsbury had his own ideas 94 was
played which at the beginning looks like
a silly loss of a temple since after a 5
it appears that I have no choice but to
retreat but prosper II was not going to
retreat he didn't play this f5 move and
I before simply to go back he had a very
keen calculation ability c6 pawn takes
before it's impossible since after c7 I
forced a promotion of the pony but that
obviously is not the problem the problem
is what happens if King d6 now the move
pawn takes f c6 if pawn takes before E
754 Singh the promotion of the pawn
however that's not the question the
question is what happens in 96 which was
played then after ninth
1666 it looks like White's just going to
lose the pawn on e6 I'm one move away
from reciting if the King gets to d6 I'm
just down upon an opponent game but
feels very he knew he calculated he was
good
efore pawn takes e4 d5 check the pawns
can now support each other since in thus
knowing that in this connected passed
pawn chain King takes d5 would fail to
e7
whereas if King d6 which was played King
III recovers the pawn on e4 thanks to
the fact that there is no f5 notice the
g5 was induced before King takes a for
King D for h5 and now I have the option
of playing h3 this is just aspiration
because I'm simply going to take all of
your pawns here on the Queen side h5
pawn takes a three a little trap if h6
b3 would win for black actually I'm not
sure it would win for black but it's
unclear
it doesn't wait for black but there's
nobody for this King c4 instead simply
defending against the third of d3 f v h6
and I'm Way too fast at four h7 and with
this in Caesar doonesbury sign and
pillsbury became the winner of 1895
Hastings a pretty nice combination
considering that it was just the night
end game and it looked pretty blah
boring draw but he made things happen
consistently made things happen the top
players from the top players from this
Hastings tournament was invited to a
further tournament in st. Petersburg and
it's widely considered that the st.
Petersburg tournament in
1895 late 1895 was one of the key
defining moments of World Championships
back then it doesn't look like Pillsbury
did very well
he finished third but actually this only
happened after he lost five games in a
row
at some point he was leading the
tournament
Pillsbury was actually crushing lasker
to one 1/2 half in their personal mini
match as you can see this is sake
Interpol round-robin which is kind of
rare nowadays but you played five times
against the same opponent and Pillsbury
destroyed Laska in their own personal
match
Steinitz was the reason actually that
Pillsbury did it wasn't just outright
running with the tournament and she
going well he wasn't having the
tournament of his life to say the least
however it looked like Pillsbury was
going to win the tournament easily and
then the following game happened this is
one of the most historically important
games in my opinion for the era the game
is Harry Nelson feels very white against
a man well Oscar as some dude that came
to the club a couple of weeks ago
Gary yeah Gary said something along the
lines garry kasparov said something
along the lines that had Pillsbury won
this game a manor Alaska would have had
no choice but to accept a world
championship match against the obvious
contender Harry Nelson Pillsbury because
of the unfavorable circumstances of the
probable match and because at that point
Pillsbury was considered to be a
stronger player that year then last year
it is very likely that the match would
have at least been very interesting with
the possibility that Pillsbury would
have been the first American World Chess
Champion however things went completely
in the opposite direction because this
game was not won by clustering instead
it was brilliantly won by a man in
Alaska so we're gonna take one of take a
look at one of the jewels of Alaska and
the start of the demise of Pillsbury's
tournament after this he lost four more
games in a row so he went from leading
the tournament to third yeah
psychologically killed the guy killed
him yeah he couldn't recover after this
he was torn and you can see from
interviews that they are in the and the
papers and the newspapers that are
covering this event the interviews that
had with Pillsbury he was just torn and
heartbroken after this loss he it took
him a long time to recover we're going
to skip again the opening because it's
not relevant for today's standards but
this is wrong for both players let's
just say this is not how we play chess
nowadays castles we don't play chess
like this well that's true
a3 Bishop d7 king b1 and we're just
gonna quickly arrive to the following
position we got a really kind of weird
game clearly there are problems for both
sides in this position blacks got an
attack on the Queen side White's trying
to crash through the King side but its
developments not quite finished yet on
the other hand it seems like if he can
control the bishops maybe there's not
that many problems for this reason
Pillsbury decided to play the move f5
the idea of f5 was that after Bishop d7
I would simply finish my development
with Bishop d3 or something along the
lines maybe defend the knight with Queen
f3 is even better and then kind of
control the position yeah instead Lasker
came up with one of the brilliant seats
of his life rook takes c3 which by
itself is not really impressed if I mean
rook takes c3 ok the idea is that if you
take and I take okay White has a lot of
problems Queen before Chuck is an issue
rook c8 is an issue I cannot really take
because of tactical reasons specifically
after takes check we'll see how this is
very dangerous in later variations
that's that are similar to this it was
just not very good however pillsbury
thought he was okay after pawn takes he
takes kind of asking what's the big deal
the make my next move is taking on f7
if you take only six maybe I have time
to take the rook but I can also finish
my development it's I'm clear and last
we came up with this move route k3 the
route goes from like being under attack
to being under attack rook a3 is one of
the most spectacular moves that has ever
been played and in such an important
game for chess history route k3
threatens the very obvious route takes a
- the question is what happens if I take
the rook we're gonna see how this all
right position is already quite
difficult for for white if first of all
if each seven which is quite interesting
rook e8 it doesn't really seem like
blacks coordination is lost we're gonna
see in which variations this is
important in which one is it but we're
always it going to start with context a
three
after pawn takes a three the idea is
Queen b6 check if King c2 the Rope comes
in with decisive effect King need to
check King e1 Chuck kingi - Chuck rugby
to check King F to check King g3 and
and the black it's not made but it's
soon to be made chezhiyan I agree with
that so you know this is not playable
even though white Supper rook he's not
going to survive if he moves to the
other side then check which rook takes
forced takes King bee one simply pawn
takes c6 black is down a piece for two
pawns but the threats of rook f2 of
Queen b6 of this King being so exposed
in this King being completely safe of
rook takes F 1 followed by Queen D 3 are
too much to handle it is impossible to
defend everything yes
you could but I think after Queenie Tory
I just go rock up to check King here and
there are no checks
notice how properly white blacks pieces
are placed in such a way that there are
no more checks in the position I mean
I'm not saying like there isn't any hope
but it's known that it's lost
I think Bishop e2 sorry Bishop peep - I
think Queen d2 yeah exactly
Bishop e2 I think we need to a swinging
something along these lines I don't
remember all of the details
if for example Bishop e2 immediately
which is a better idea
rook a queen a 424 checking a one Rock
f2 is known to be a decisive attack
again it's not like I'm winning right
now but black-white eventually cannot
hold this position together it's just
too much instead of that Pillsbury
thought to interject a move pawn takes
f7 check before anything happened route
takes f7 is forced we cannot allow this
pawn to survive on f7 as I would create
a distraction to the rook later in the
position also remember that I had to
take on e6 at some point in these
variations right B takes a three check
and now a very clever move Bishop b5 the
resourcefulness of these players for
being before 1900 is amazing King one is
no good because a bishop takes d4 and
the lines that we just saw are basically
accelerated as the pawn on e6 had no
special value whereas the penetration of
the rook coming in one move earlier is
particularly important King C two rooks
e7 check simply loses the same as the
previous variations so pillsbury tries
to play Bishop e5 destroying the
coordination between Queen and Bishop so
that after Queen takes b5 I can hide on
a1 pillsbury retains a material advance
he is up the exchange but it is clear
that he is not playing for a win at the
moment his King is very exposed
now unfortunately or very fortunately
for chess fans last year he makes a
mistake the correct continuation would
have been Queen c4 and after queen g4
control the other file with rookie 7
training things like rookie 2 and taking
advantage of the fact that you cannot
compete for this square for example
after rook H e1 Bishop takes d4 Jack
Queen takes d4 takes sorry Queen takes
d4 rocky one you cannot take on c4
because check so after for example Queen
d2 rook takes Queen takes we have a
pretty obviously one queen Ian game
the King is much too exposed on on a1 I
have a free pass pawn and almost all
opponent games are hopeless
unfortunately last can play Droog c7 but
that allowed Pillsbury to just enough
time to defend ruk t2 was a strong move
trying to put this rook in the defense
either on b1 or on d1 or e1 rooks e4 and
Men another mistake route d1 which was
known as a blunder the correct move
would have been rook e1 but already this
position is very hard to understand the
idea would have been a clever perpetual
after for example Queen a5 now notice
that I cannot take on d4 because after
takes takes check King h5 Queen f5 check
it's white that mates black so a very
double-edged position instead after for
example rock a1 Queen a5 would have been
good but then a brilliant draw that
Pillsbury missed check King h7 check
g6 now I cannot take on f6 because Chuck
and I lose I get made it first
I cannot check because we should g7 but
I have the brilliant Ruki seven if
retreats Chuck and Chuck made if
retreats check and checkmate
if Bishop g7 Chuck leads to similar
ideas that we're gonna see and if Bishop
takes seven check King here Chuck here
Chuck and perpetual instead rook HD one
was played defending the pawn on d4 but
here rook c3 a mistake allowing white to
again go rook e1 but already in time
trouble Queen f5 was played Queen c4 and
I think that even though the mistakes
were there and this is not a perfect
game the way that it finished is so
iconic that it makes it all worth it to
me
King b2 was played King b1 is correct
actually after rook takes rook c1 why
it's actually winning
and as Kasparov says chess history would
have gone down a completely different
path but alas it was not to be king b2
was the choice by Pillsbury and the
brilliant second time in this game rook
takes a three again this rook c3 to a3
idea two times in one game sacrificing a
full rook both cases pillsbury after
Queen e6 King h7 in his exhaustion
finally collapses he cracks under
pressure he should not have taken this
he should have defended fiercely with
Queen a5 check and after King h8 played
retreated the King even though his
position is still unpleasant there was a
draw at hand
instead King takes a three was played
and was brilliantly made it after queen
c3 check King a 4 B 5 check King takes B
5 Queen C for Chuck King a5 Bishop da
check cream b6 that [ __ ] takes me six
checkmate
now you can see why Pillsbury was so
heartbroken after this game this was
huge
feels very returned to America he played
as I said many tournaments were he did
quite well he was always playing in
exhibition matches and he was regarded
as a very nice guy and as a player with
immeasurable strength his talent was
really there unfortunately it was this
tournament not only that he not only did
he lose in this tournament and you know
catastrophically played the second half
of the of the event but he actually also
contracted syphilis well he was in in
st. Petersburg yeah he was known as a
you know gentlemen wine women that
eventually cost him his life and that
was like that was why he died so young
of course
Lasker had a different idea of why he
died Alaska wrote an obituary for him in
the New York Times for Pillsbury and he
was complaining about the lack of money
for chess players back then and he was
always saying the blindfold exhibitions
especially at the level that Pillsbury
played with dozens of games at the same
time blindfolded and multitasking we're
causing him quote over extension of his
memory cells which is according to last
game why Pillsbury died even though
there is no medical theory that says
that anybody dies out of memory cell
overextension but I guess when it's a
teen or like 19 whatever 1905 and you're
the world chess champion you can say
whatever you want you can make it up and
yeah something like that Pillsbury kind
of like morphe was really a pity the
fact that he died so young it seems like
he never really reached his potential
he was never again as strong after he
contracted his disease as he was in 1895
slash 1896 he took the world of chess by
storm and it was very very brief he only
had a five-year period where you can say
Pillsbury was one of the best players of
the world only five years when you say
that last year was world champion for
over 20 when you compare Kasparov career
when you think of any of the greats you
think of the trajectory of years look at
cautionary how long has he been playing
chess does Barry play chess at the top
level for five years and despite that he
had such results that we remember him
even today that's one of the greatest
American chess players who ever lived
his genius his charm his surprise was
just unbelievable and Pillsbury yes yeah
get away against them on where last care
yeah yeah it is yeah it is fun with
Lasker this is their match in sorry that
their game in Nuremberg in Germany 1896
and we're gonna see a classical French
now again no I don't worry about the
theory yeah nobody plays like this but
we're just gonna get to the meat of the
story especially since I have four
minutes left h5b six takes takes Bishop
III so Lasker takes a free pawn with
this last move and then Pillsbury he
gets his revenge
f5 clearing the f-4 square for his night
sacrificing a second pawn pawn takes a
4/9
a five-night f4 simply improving the
night h4 was played rook e1 Bishop e7
and a barrage of sacrifices
Ruth takes a for the ship takes a for
distracting the bishop from its
important task of defending the e6
square Knight takes c6 pawn takes c6
Knight takes c6 and here Lasker realized
that if he moves his queen he basically
gets made it if for example Queen d7
Queen takes a five is pretty much near
decisive Queen g6 or Queen f7 are coming
night c7 is a threat there is no good
square for the Queen so he decided his
best resource was to simply play Bishop
d7 and try to survive this position and
pillsbury we had none of that he easily
destroyed last year from here takes
takes Queen III rooks the six shark here
Roxy one trade a couple of rooks very
nice technique you always want to get
rid of the rooks when you're playing
Queen against rook and Bishop rook c8
Queen e1 double attack h3 all right free
pawn rook g8 King F 2 a for Queen B for
keeping this guy in check and running
Queen d6 King up three basically zooms
on King a forest coming a3 was played
trying to add this get rid of this point
take through takes p6 Quincy 556 Queen
c7 give me 70 near for p6h for Roxy so X
Queen be a king your Bam Bam and
Laska recent but a very very very
beautiful idea this f5 preparing a
sacrifice that looks completely
illogical you cannot sacrifice 26 it's
the most overprotective thing that black
has but her k1 Bishop e7 takes on a four
just like whatever ripping apart the
entire defense Bishop a4 96 takes 96 man
and it was so powerful like last year
didn't even move the Queen thank you ken
was the queen feels very you know he
could have been he could have been it
but yeah he played a lot of good games
he's game against a tush in the second
round of Hastings was absolutely
brilliant outplayed his opponent he had
a lot of beautiful attacks and even
though I mean it was only five years of
top-level chess he will always be known
as you know the greatest American player
after palm working